(relaxing music)
- Hi, everybody.
This is Heinrich from Firm
Learning and welcome back.
Welcome back to my channel where I try
to help you be successful in
the first years of your career.
As you know, here if you
are a constant listener
to my channel, one important
skill to be successful
in many, many organizations is PowerPoint.
And in this video, I'm
sharing a tip with you
on how you can actually improve one little
but significant detail of
your work in PowerPoint.
Because there's one thing
that only a very few
people know in PowerPoint,
and this is that, PowerPoint, by default,
messes up your text boxes.
If you insert a new
text box in PowerPoint,
it will be messed up and
not be created in a way
that you actually wanted to be
and that's actually helpful
for you to work with it.
This video will show you why
and it will show you how to fix that.
So that by default, if
you insert new text boxes,
they will look exactly like you need them
and in a helpful and constructive way.
This little detail I learned
in probably my first week at McKinsey
where one of the most senior associates
taught it to me because
I created the pages
in a way that just were not good
because I made this specific
error and did not fix that.
The video that you're seeing now
is an except of my course on
how to make PowerPoint presentations
the way that top
management consultants do.
If you're interested to learn more,
feel free to look into
the description below
where I have the link to
the full course included.
I have more than 10,000
students taking the course
with literally hundreds of reviews.
So if you would like to learn
more what the course is about
and whether it's interesting to you,
check it out and look at the link
to see more about it.
So now I would like to show you something
that will really help you to improve
the way you make your
slides and your pages
and will really help
you to spend less time
to align all the elements on your page.
It would be, I think, quite an improvement
of your workflow.
The topic is fix your text boxes.
The reason why I'm saying that is that
there's actually quite a problem
with the default text boxes in PowerPoint.
Let me just show you one example
to really make it clear what I mean.
Let's look at this page.
This is just a random example page
that I prepared here for you.
Now let's imagine this
text box wouldn't be there.
So I delete it now.
And we wanted to include
a new text box here.
So what would I do usually?
I would here, click on 'text box,'
in order for me to insert a new text box.
So click here to create a new one.
Now I'll type in some kind of text,
probably something like, I don't know.
So this is the column potential offerings,
so 'create new casino offering,'
something like that.
Obviously it doesn't make much sense now
but just as an example.
Let's include a bullet here.
Now you'll see the
formatting is a bit off.
This is Calibri, the rest
of the page is in Ariel.
So let's make this Ariel and
I think the font size was 14.
So let's enter that as well.
Now the text box should be exactly like
these other text boxes.
Or is that maybe not the case?
What I want to show you
is now the following.
Imagine how you want to
nicely fit this new text box
in the page and by doing
that we would like to
align it to this upper element here.
And aligning means that
would really start here
at the left border of it.
And you see all the other text boxes
with their bullet points,
they neatly start here
at the left edge of this element.
And this gives it a nice and clean look.
We will have the later section
on alignment of elements.
But let's dive into it here at this point
and say we would like to
align it to this left edge.
Probably the easiest way of doing that
would be to click here on 'arrange.'
'Align' and 'left.'
Now this is PowerPoint on a Mac.
I usually always also
use the Windows version.
The guide I think looks a bit different
but you will find this arrange pendant
somewhere in your Windows
PowerPoint as well.
Now we aligned it here on the left, right?
It is supposed to start
here at the left corner.
Now maybe let's.
Whoops.
Let's try to center this a bit.
Like this.
Actually we need to move it up
in order to make it symmetric together.
Fine.
What is now the problem that
we see with this element?
The problem is that if you look closely,
it isn't really starting at the left edge
of this thing.
You will see it if you
mark all these objects,
that here the dot directly
starts at the edge of the border
of the box, but here it doesn't.
There is some kind of distance in between.
And this is actually quite a problem
with the text boxes how they are created
as a default in PowerPoint.
Because if you create a new text box,
it automatically inserts
a border to the left,
to the right, to the
top, and to the bottom.
And this makes it really
hard to neatly align
the text boxes to each other.
Because imagine now if all text boxes
would look like this text box.
Just to demonstrate that to you
I will now copy this format and apply it
to the other boxes.
If you don't know it, you can
use this format icon here.
If you double click on it,
you can use it several times.
If I now click here, it gets transformed
to the format of the reference object
that was marked or
highlighted in the beginning.
Now, of course, the size is out of bounds
but that is not really the issue.
We can just fix that.
Like that.
Now we've got to fix that as well
to where you can close it.
If we focus now here on the left border,
what's the problem?
The problem is that now
it isn't really neatly alignment here.
The issue is that there's literally no way
for me to, with the
automatic alignment functions
that PowerPoints provide,
to make it neatly start
here at the end.
Because if I use these autofitting guides,
it will just give me the guide
on the edge of the border
but not really the guide
where the point starts.
So the only thing I can
do is manually try to
put it more or less
closely to where I think
the right position is,
which is obviously super cumbersome.
And if you want to align
lots of objects on your page,
it would take ages and it's
just not a good work flow.
Let's go back to where it was before.
What you actually need to do
in order to fix this text
box is the following.
You right click on it
and click 'format shape.'
Then some kind of menu will pop up.
And here if you click on this icon here
and within the text box sub-menu,
you can 'resize shape to fit text'
and then, more important here,
the left margin, right margin,
top margin, and bottom margin.
And you should put these all to zero.
What you see now, now we've got this
kind of clean, neat, text box design.
And if we move it somewhere else,
and we want to realign it to
this reference header box,
you just click align left.
It neatly starts on the exact same level
where the others start.
This is where it's supposed to be.
Now the next thing you can do,
because obviously it's quite annoying
to have to fix every
single text box this way.
There's one function
existing within PowerPoint
in order to make this text box style
the new default style.
And if you right-click on the text box,
on the border of the text box,
you get this possibility to
'set as default text box.'
If you click this, now PowerPoint knows
that we want all text boxes to be created
exactly in this way.
The next time that we
insert a new text box,
let's do that right now.
I insert something,
I insert a random text in it,
and you're noticing that it
looks exactly the way it should.
If we now align it to this text box,
'align left,' it's neatly
aligned with all the other boxes.
And this is how we want it.
So here's my really
important recommendation
that you set the text
boxes exactly in this way.
You do not want to have any borders
around your elements that
are automatically inserted.
Because otherwise the
whole alignment process
within PowerPoint will not work properly.
It will just be a huge pain, huge pain,
to get neatly formatted
and neatly aligned pages.
So do yourself this favor
and it will help you
throughout the rest of the course.
Thank you for watching, everybody.
I hope you found this valuable.
Again, this is an
excerpt of my full course
on creating top management
slide presentations
in the way that companies
like BCG or McKinsey do.
If you would like to learn more about it,
look into the description below
where I include the link.
If this video was at all helpful to you,
please press the like button.
If you would like to learn more
and keep watching other content
that I have prepared for you
for the next weeks and months,
please subscribe to this channel
to stay posted about all the news
that I have lined up for you.
This is Heinrich from Firm Learning,
thank you for watching.